People often talk about the importance of
detecting and dealing with outliers in your
data. But there are many types of
outliers and anomalies and how your analysis proceeds
should depend on what type you're dealing
with. Outliers can have many causes. For
example, an outlier might be accurate data
about an extreme case. For example, someone represented
in your data set might really be tweeting 1,000 times a day. On the other
hand, sometimes outliers, or anomalies represent bad data,
or the limitations of your data. For example,
what otherwise would be a normal value of a variable might be replaced with an
extreme value. Or, in other cases, extreme values
might be replaced with a more normal value.
For example, in a lot of census data or surveys, income information
is top coded. So individuals with very large incomes have their incomes
replaced with some other value. Let's get back to Mora's story about perceived
audience size, and hear about a particular anomaly that popped up there.